the legal trap starts out with E4 E5 net
F3 Knight C6 pretty common Bishop to C4
Pawn D6 solidifying the pawn chain here
Knight to C3 Bishop coming down pinning
down the knights and pawn H3 forcing the
bishop back the bishop really should be
capturing here but if they come back to
H5 this is where the legal trap can be
deployed and that is Knight takes on E5
says yeah if you want to pin down my
knight to the queen I don't really care
because if you take my queen
that's gonna end up in Checkmate no way
for black to stop this bishop comes here
to F7 the King has only one move this D7
square is protected by the Knight
King comes to E7 and then Knight to D5
and this is Checkmate in a very fun and
interesting way